brian griese here on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line on the rich housing show
how you doing brian
good morning rich great to be with you
right back at you man uh that that uh
monday night game what do you take out
of that one the one that we just saw
between the rams and the cardinals brian
what do you what do you what's portable
that we can apply to the last month of
the season do you think
with that yeah i think uh coming into
the game obviously what sean mcvay and
and the rams were dealing with from the
kogut standpoint of of losing
uh
five starters uh for that game jaylen
ramsey havenstein the the offensive
lineman higbee big big contributors for
the rams
both sides of the football and and for
them you know honestly coming into the
game i was trying to figure out
what is the recipe how are they going to
to win this football game on the road
against an arizona team which had been
hot
and i felt like the response from from
the stars from the aaron donalds from
the von miller from
matthew stafford and what they were able
to do with cooper cup throughout the
course of the game i think that this
rams team
which
everybody was talking so much about
super bowl or bust all in
obj von miller bring all the individual
stars and they were a collection of
individual players hall of fame type
players but they really needed to find a
way to play as a team
and that was the
theme for us throughout the course of
the game was watching them play as a
team complementary football the things
that aren't sexy situational football um
and they won that game because of those
reasons uh conversely the arizona
cardinals were not good in situational
football and managing the clock late uh
and making the plays that they needed to
make and turning the football over so
taking from that game rich is the rams
are going to be there at the end they're
going to be in the hunt
for the nfc west potentially uh but
certainly for for the wild card and if
they get in and matthew stafford
continues to play at a high level and
sony michelle continues to play at a
high level and they get dell henderson
back and they establish that physical
run game and play action uh maybe they
can compete in the nfc that that's what
i took away yeah and then my question is
is how sustainable is that for
for the rams and and i i think it is and
the guy who i think that makes it
sustainable is sony michelle and i know
you were talking about it during the
broadcast about the
the uh you know the running and his
ability to to give the offense what they
need not just in yards and staying on
schedule but also the play action
everything that comes out of that i
asked that of andrew whitworth yesterday
and and and he agreed that he he kind of
gives them what cj anderson did in their
super bowl season of a few years ago
brian you know yeah and an attitude rich
right i mean he came uh it came from new
england he understands how to play the
game he has been coached well and he
understands how a physical run game can
impact a team
um and i think that you know they lost
robert woods about a month ago and he he
was not just a great receiver but he was
the dog on that offense he was the
competitive nature he would not back
down from anybody he's the guy you want
in the alley in a fight right and they
lost more than just a great wide
receiver with robert woods they lost an
attitude and a competitiveness and it's
taken them a while
to kind of get back and i think sony
michelle brings a little bit of that and
and if nothing else um to have that
attitude and the huddle uh that belief
um and obviously he's he's a physical
player but i i think that they were
missing that and you know the offensive
line has gotten better um they won
on monday night without two starters on
the offensive line um they lost you know
one of their best uh
playmakers and tyler higby wasn't there
and they needed to to rise up and and to
respond with their backs against the
wall and sony michelle brought that
attitude i thought brian griese here uh
on the rich eisen show and then you saw
patriots and bills the week before i
mean what a crazy game that was wild to
say the least um so you're the perfect
person to ask about this you know about
what to make of the bills in their last
four weeks of the season um what ails
them what do you think needs to be fixed
even though their last quarter and a
half and tampa might have shown that
they did finally catch a stride that
they could ride no doubt to the playoffs
but what do you think
is the missing ingredient from this
year's team that was maybe there last
year what do you got for me yeah i you
know i think rich i think that we get um
you know those of us that cover the nfl
on a week in and week out basis i think
sometimes we get so caught up on a week
to week and we try to find um
what a team is or the definition of a
team on a weekend a week out bit like
this week the arizona cardinals are dead
right
there's something wrong with them you
know they're ten and three you know uh
we did that with the rams and i and i
think now we're experiencing that with
the buffalo bills and um and so i i
listen
what happened in orchard park against
the new england patriots to me that was
an outlier that was that that game was
completely different the the elements i
mean standing on that field before the
game and i'm sitting there talking to
josh allen and the guy that with the
strongest arm in the national football
league and i'm like hey bud where can
you throw it he's like really i really
can only throw it to this
southeast corner because everything else
is moving and i'm like but you got the
strongest arm in the lead you're telling
me that's the only place you're
comfortable throwing it and he's like
yeah i'm like okay i got it uh i think
that the weather mitigated what the
bills do well in that game and it
accentuated what the patriots do well
and i think that's why they won that
game
but in a in a dome you know
that that game could have come out
completely different um then they have
to follow up against against the
buccaneers who you know i think is one
of the hottest teams in the league and
and
and they listen they could have easily
won that game i loved what they did in
the second half and you're not going to
play four quarters of perfect pristine
football all the time but do you have
what it takes in the end in the second
half the fourth quarter does your star
and josh allen make the plays that he
needs to make to win the game
and i felt like josh allen did that laid
it out all on the line and they can move
forward from that and they just made the
mistake of giving you know the best ever
you know one more opportunity
uh but i i'm not i'm not down on the
bills i think that they're going to
regroup i think that they have what they
need they have everything they need to
compete in the playoffs and
we'll see if they can use these last
couple of weeks as a rallying cry no you
know and so who do you take in the afc
and i'm looking at the list here you've
had the ravens a couple of times and you
had them uh when you know they were
playing their best football all year you
had the titans and bills in week six you
saw the chiefs against the giants in
week eight that was when they were
beginning to make that turn around
defensively and i know people were
passing it off it was just the giants
but we've seen since then not an outlier
you had the chargers beat the raiders
that was so long ago gruden was the
coach
so you know you put it all together
um who who do you who are you putting
your marker on in the afc brian griese
entering week 15. what do you got for me
here i think you got to look at the
teams that are playing the best maybe
who are not the best teams or the best
rosters but who's playing the best
football and right now it's the new
england patriots and the kansas city
chiefs are playing the best football and
uh and in the case we know about the
patriots okay we understand what's going
on there and and with a rookie
quarterback and when you get to the
playoffs um you know everything's
different and and we don't know what
we're going to get from a rookie
quarterback we know what we're going to
get from
99 percent of the rest of that roster
and that coaching staff
we understand that
um but there is that that outlying
question uh with the chiefs you know
defensively what they have been able to
do and i know chris jones get a little
bit nicked up but i i think what they've
been able to do and i give credit to
steve stagnola this is not the first
time he's done this right uh where he's
got had defense uh to play their best
when the when it requires their best
towards the end of the season and into
the playoffs um so certainly i think the
chiefs are right there i'm concerned
about baltimore on a number of levels um
and what's going on
there tennessee i'm concerned about in
fact
you know that division you look at who's
playing the best you could argue it's
the indianapolis colts and and what
they're doing right now and i think
that's a team
to keep an eye out for uh you mentioned
the chargers uh i i'm fired up about
tomorrow night i think what a great
opportunity for for that team
uh for justin herbert uh who i think is
playing some of his best football so
there's a lot of teams there rich i i
understand that um
i think that i think that probably the
division with the most problems is the
north is the afc north and i can't put a
finger on who's going to come out right
because i don't think that any of those
teams are playing well right now brian
greasy here on the rich eisen show let's
do this for the nfc too um
you know you you had the packers back in
week two i mean that was when uh rogers
apparently didn't care about football
because he got blown out in week one
against new orleans and then we've seen
differently uh we've you know you saw
the bucks against the giants week 11.
uh cowboys week three against the eagles
that's so long ago
so
what do you got i mean who do you have
for me right now on the nfc you've seen
a few of these teams in person but now
that you're watching them play right now
what do you got for me uh when it all
comes down uh going in a week 15 on that
front brian yeah you know i think it
starts with with the two ogs the two
guys that are in the mvp race there's no
question about that i think you know
what you're going to get from the
packers and the bucks and so uh i i
think those two are a given um i think
there's a lot of questions about the
cardinals i'm not giving up on the
cardinals but just watching them in
person uh monday night um there there
are some issues that they have i think
in their confidence level in in the
second half of games and finishing games
and playing situational football and
kyler murray protecting the ball
they are explosive and they are good on
the defensive end they didn't play well
in the secondary uh on monday night
which i i was hoping and anticipating
them to play well under vance joseph but
but they didn't uh i'm a big fan of
jalen thompson and buddha baker marco
wilson and i think they'll bounce back
so i i think that they'll win the west
um you know i i think that the rams will
have a chance like i said the 49ers are
a team that are
scary
that that is just so physical
um and i think they find a way to sneak
in and i know there's no team in the nfc
that wants to face that run game i agree
uh and as their defense continues to get
better george kittle is so hot right now
um so i i think that's a team that's
going to be there and then you know so
everybody wants to know about the dallas
cowboys and and i you know i i'm a
little concerned about what i've seen
from that prescott um i believe that he
has what it takes to take this team deep
into the playoffs but he's got to play
better and they got to play better
around him um and thankfully for him you
know michael parsons and his defense
incredible uh has been playing lights
out it's been really fun to watch them
i'm you know we have a flex
in week 18 on monday night we'll have a
double header on saturday i'm hopeful
maybe we get dallas
um or maybe san francisco i know they
play the rams that'll be a big game uh
in week 18 but it's going to come down
to the very end you know that rich yeah
i know dad that's for sure brian greasy
here on the rich eisens show uh with the
time i'll have left for you here what
was brady like in the quarterback room
in 1997
for michigan in that national
championship gear that you quarterbacked
what was he like
back in that day brian
well he had long hair rich
so did i brian so did i
so did i yeah
his hairstyle was not great back then
he's definitely he's definitely got that
in shape now uh you know he was he was a
joy to be around he was a sponge like
you would imagine he was a sponge he
wanted to absorb everything he possibly
could he was competitive
you know he wanted to be in my seat you
know he wanted my job and we competed
for that position
and um and we competed hard and both of
us had to wait our turn at michigan i
think i was number six on the depth
chart when i got there and it was very
similar for him we had younger guys
ahead of us on the depth chart he had to
go through the whole drew henson saga i
i had a very similar situation with
scott dreisbach um so we we were uh we
were hardened and um by those
experiences and and then we identified
with each other because of that because
we had to fight and scratch and claw for
every opportunity we got at michigan and
and i was so happy when he got his
chance and um and watched him play and
and i'm fired up rich to watch the uh
the orange bowl this georgia game tell
me about it um i'm really excited and
happy for those seniors you know the
aiden hutchinsons and kate mcnamara and
haskins that that came back
that they finally got to the big ten
championship they finally got the ohio
state monkey off their back and and i'm
so excited to watch that game against
georgia and proud of uh proud of the
alma mater josh gaddis you know winning
the broyles and and mike mcdonald the
defensive coordinator you know mike
mcdonald rich yes sir is a
alumnus of georgia
uh he was there uh as a coach as well
from 2010 to 13. so you know he's going
to have something cooked up i'm excited
to watch those guys play yeah and you
could say cade mcnamara is kind of like
right like he had milton in front of him
it was it was last year it was kind of
like okay
let's let's try kade right you know what
i mean like let's give him a whirl and
now what he's done this year also i'm
not saying mccarthy's like drew henson
right but he's got to come off the field
every now and then and and the other kid
gets reps and that can't be easy
and there there are some similarities
here all i'm saying is michigan's going
to win it all that's what i'm saying
brian you know and i'm living my best
life you know and this is this is
amazing uh this is awesome it's just
been so great
honestly well i'm i'm i'm fired up for
you that you finally have something to
crow about
by the way i don't know if you've been
aware crow i don't think does uh does
justice what i have been doing here
my guys here are shaking their heads on
their set
honestly
brian if you haven't seen any of the
videos it's much more than crowing oh my
god i wrote so many checks after ohio
state it was so great it was so great
you know for you listen all of the
michigan alumni have your back rich you
go right ahead yes brian greasy that's a
national champion saying that to me true
that fantastic and i love watching what
you're doing too brian thanks for the
time let's uh let's chat down the road
okay thank you okay guys you bet that's
brian greasy everybody check him and uh
leaves and and louis riddick monday
night football vikings bears big game
for the vikings big game for the vikings
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here